all right here we are back on gamespot
stage live from the show floor at e3
2014 and the next demo is kingdom hearts
2.5 HD remix joining me is way from the
co-director on the game and tie you
brought a little something with you yes
that's right i brought the Keyblade with
me um that is a massive safety has it
made Laurie do you know how to handle it
yes I do actually I don't gotta move
it's exciting for me I'm taking a lot of
pictures with this aha so do you get to
keep that like I think they'll send it
back to me in Japan alright yeah after
the e3 they may be 43 maybe not gonna
fit in the overhead compartment a
probably arrest me I mean alright tight
ok the martes 2.5 HD remix I you know
the kingdom hearts series up what a huge
fan base and a lot of people just really
love the game you guys had kingdom
hearts 1.5 HD remix sort of taken the
games putting them together you know it
sort of remastering some of them lay out
for us what exactly goes into this pack
okay well we're kinked up parts 2.5 we
left off from 1.5 and we've included
kingdom hearts birth by sleep which is
the origin story for Kingdom Hearts and
also we've included kingdom hearts 2
these are two of my favorite actually
king of Mars titles i really enjoyed
them very much they're both final mixes
so they've never been played in the US
or europe yet and also we've included
Kingdom Hearts recoded which is a three
hour massive theater full of cutscenes
so people can enjoy that too actually
really enjoy to learn about the queendom
art story I think so it's a 2 the 2 full
games plus the the cut scenes from
recoded that's right and I which which
one are we looking at here would give a
set of all days brother what we're
seeing here Kingdom Hearts to
Halloweentown this is one of my favorite
world store i goes to the world called
nightmare before christmas yeah even up
with jack skellington runs around there
Jack Stanton wants to celebrate
Christmas and so he saw us out like any
skeleton does and this is beasts castle
heartless have sort of attacked this
world and mouse Aurora has to fight the
boss heartless it's called the shadow
stalker he actually jumps into the map
he becomes the lights the pillar
and you have to really use of a reaction
command to get rid of them actually and
that's kinda into using the you know
sort of polluting this environment if
you know you'll recognize from Beauty
and the Beast and then that chandelier
turns right and becomes really sinister
I guess one of the points is I am making
Kingdom ours you really don't want to
change too much of the world but we
actually want to add a lot to it so that
was I gets difficult to plan for the
remix we actually remade the textures
the UI's everything environments and so
it is more beautiful i guess and the
previous kingdom hearts 2 yeah so
there's a station to talk a little bit
about the the final mix cuz that you
know came out in japan a lot of work
went into that what sort of specifically
did you guys we typically we added a lot
of basketball boss battles for the final
mix you could fight the organization 13
there's missions with mushrooms that's
kind of fun one of my favorite battles
is with lingering will he's like armored
a character his weapons keyblade really
changes and transforms into different
shapes that's very exciting as well yeah
and a lot of new abilities and all of
you styles that you could use and choose
from this is what really well received
in japan and we're really happy get out
of here with you in the US Stan per
second that's it I guess December second
is coming out and then of course there's
also in the works just kingdom hearts 3
that's right we're working on that right
now as well simultaneously and that's
pretty exciting i can't tell you much
about and bursting to tell you actually
as a developer a lot of technology new a
lot of technology creative stuff is
going in leaps and bounds and i think
well not this i can't really count known
as yours yet that was targeting the xbox
one and the PlayStation a water station
forward so I think that's going to
really evolve the kingdom hearts series
alright well so kingdom hearts 2 point 5
for xbox 360 ps3 actually it's a ps3 or
just ps3 to ever do that networks was it
pardon me I and so we're you know in the
midst of one of these sort of big boss
battles but in Kingdom Hearts you also
gets it to spend time exploring these
places that part is that is part of the
ideas characters yeah um we really
recreated Disney's features
but you can actually explore interacts
with their characters and sort of has
its own original story as well so you
can both enjoy the disney store add the
kingdom hearts the stories one of the
reasons we may think mark 1.5 and 2.5 is
this huge saga that actually anthon
kingdom hearts 3 all the dark seeker
saga immune and so by playing 1.5 in 2.5
i think you get a deeper understanding
of a story of Kingdom Hearts 3 it's
really there's a lot of threads story
threads it's amazing how you how you
guys have created these you know the
Disney story for an offense in the
kingdom hearts like like just all in all
intertwines and it's always been so
incredible to me how you like working
with Disney a company which is very
protective and loving with its with its
with its characters with its world but
it's art how is it how is it to work
with them as a developer actually they
have a lot of love and passion for
Kingdom arts as well so I guess yeah we
give them ideas we give them more and
see how that goes I think it's all about
having a lot of respect to the original
IPS and also for the kingdom hearts I've
see right so you don't really want to
change what's good about the Disney
feature films or animations right so and
we also have well for our ideas you have
to come up with a gameplay designs and
everything and that has to work as well
so i guess it's very there's a lot of
constraints but because of those
constraints i think we they force us to
really think you ought to get every a
get to make it work yeah these you know
these guidelines yeah how can we make
yeah that's right i guess that yeah that
as a creator that's very challenging but
i guess yeah i believe it i believe it
alright so now we're having a little
encounter ok this is Ventus from kingdom
hearts birth by sleep he's playing in
Cinderella's stage inside Cinderella's
house and he has to find a dress dress
materials for Cinderella or she goes to
the ball this is Lucifer the cat oh my
goddess closer in that smile and there's
like sinister eyes that can yeah Ventus
has to fight this cat he rides on his
back and everything and the map itself
is very actually a three-dimensional
vertical and he has to find a lot of
pieces from a mouse point of view so
that's kind of interesting as well and
that's you know so that must be another
consideration is what what perspective
do you take you know
when you when you sort of come into this
world you know are you playing ssin are
you meeting Cinderella nor you her sighs
are you the mouse sighs are you both you
know can you could actually yeah we have
a lot of room to actually navigate with
that for example yeah cinderelly the
first things Ventus the character is a
mouse it's sort of found in a mousetrap
and so he sort of becomes friends with
Jack the mouse and they sort of interact
but the other characters there's two
more characters player characters called
Terra and Aqua babe come in normal sizes
and so you could actually interact with
Cinderella as well just with the same
size one of the better fun points of
birth by sleep is you have three
characters that you can control and
they're sort of Destiny's intertwined
and they sort of visit same worlds but
they sort of play in a different story
and they've all got kind of different
skill sets that's right different skill
set yeah this is Sarah he's a manly guy
he is very he she sort of uses like
meat-eor and I usually use a lot of
rocks Rock style abilities magic this is
the ultimate cannon which is which is
like a shot lock system you get to lock
on to several several enemies at once
and fire at once sort of there's a lot
of experimentation with a battle from
birth by sleep and this is aqua our hero
in this is khiry actually one of the
favorite Kingdom Hearts characters when
she was little uh-huh so birth by sleep
is was really cooked part at the
beginning before kingdom hearts one so
you get a little up history of the
kingdom hearts series and speaking of
that history we have some questions
coming in Maya Twitter just a reminder
folks if you have any questions about
the games you're seeing on our life
stages today to send them to me via
Twitter to add CT waters or use the
hashtag gamespot III I'll be sure to
pass them along and you can also put
them in the gamespot chat and we'll take
a look there this one is coming in from
Wayne Gibson wondering you know as
someone who hasn't played the
franchising before I how accessible is a
story for him for people like him and is
is 2.5 a good starting place well
actually um probably 1.5 would be the
best starting place but you know a
kingdom hearts Oh each has a story for
each Disney World so that is pretty easy
understand and I guess there is the
original Kingdom Hearts story which is a
bit more difficult and if you want to
learn about that I guess 1.5 would be a
better starting point would be the place
to go that's right ah but when you're
playing 2.5 you sort of do you guys
Stitch the games together at all or is
it sort of like a fire up the game in
which one you die you know we really
wanted to give the player the freedom to
choose which game to play first right so
you have a launcher system on the title
and you actually choose from three
different games okay yeah so and so
we've seen two of them so far the third
one is is actually not the the full
recoded game but it's the cinematic
that's right the cinematic and we
totally recreated that in 3d it was
originally for the DX right so we can
use that yeah we had a 35-member cutting
team doing working for maybe half a year
we made a lot of 3 hours worth of
cutscenes so that's a lot taken knows
what it is to the place take that's
right yeah so a lot of work to be done a
lot of models a lot of environments and
totally be made that so I think if you'd
like story I guess you could really
enjoy that and how is that structured it
just in terms of how the player goes
through and and she's all that okay well
you know recoded really i think connects
a lot of the kingdom hearts sort of yes
the best way maybe to play would be
starting at birth by sleep because it's
the origin story and then you go the
kingdom hearts 2 when sora you actually
play with Sora and I guess recoated
recoded in recording you play in a
virtual computer world and you have to
find a hidden message and the Sidon
message explains about the heroes in
printing large brush by sleeves okay so
that sort of connects everything I think
in a way story connects the kingdom
hearts 2 birth by sleep and also kingdom
march three very cool so we've sort of
asked about a newcomer coming into this
but for fans who have played these games
before and experience this world what's
what what do you guys what do you think
would it taste them back to play again
well you know um for kingdom hearts 2
final mix and birth by sleep I think by
recreating this on the ps3 console it
has really realized its full potential
the colors are more vivid the characters
are more sharp expressions or more
animated everything and so I think he
got a real deeper deeper experience not
just the graphics I guess the sound as
well for Kingdom arch too we recreated
90 and over 90 of our songs we had an
orchestra with live instruments
40-member steering Orchestra and we
reported that a lot of effort is put
into the details right so I guess if you
have to feel the whole thing I guess the
whole package well speaking of sort of
all the loving care that's gone into
these cutscenes Emily Noel on Twitter
wants to know personally for you going
through these games and revisiting them
is there something that sort of stands
out as one of your favorite moments one
of your favorite things to see in the
final remix and in HD remix or you know
i'm actually at work right now i'm
fighting the boss battles for kingdom
hearts 2 final mix and they're very
difficult I guess that's so yeah yeah
I'm finding boxes actually Sora and
Roxas is battle is really amazing I
think I'm in Japan it was very
well-reviewed something that really like
to give to users I players in North
America and Europe and that's exciting I
think for a lot of you know American
European kingdom hearts fans because so
often they're these beloved Japanese
games that you know don't don't actually
find a release outside of Japan and so
maybe you try to import or maybe you
just clamor on Kingdom Hearts forums for
you guys but we bring this to other
markets so have people been pretty
excited about it yeah I guess everyone
has everyone's been really passionate at
the e3 actually I'm uh I get all my
energy here um yeah working in
development very tiring but once I come
here I receive all this passion for
Kingdom Hearts and that really energizes
the dev team and me alright one last
question i'm sure you probably can't
answer but i gotta say it anyways eric
song huh wondering if there's any chance
of frozen baking it in well you know are
frozen personally I can't make any
announcements but personally I love
frozen um the magic that you know the
ice expressions of ice my the snowflakes
are really beautiful I think they would
make good fit but there's no
announcements yet so you have to stay
tuned i guess but personally i love
frozen i think it's yeah it's amazingly
popular it's amazing the proper yeah
alright ty kingdom hearts 2.5 HD remix
tell us again when it's coming out it's
coming out December second in north
america
and said december fifth in europe and
europe and the playstation 3's i play
safe in three now all right thank you so
much for coming okay thank you for
watching the part look I'm gay do you
want to leave this here okay maybe hang
on over a little bit for a little bit
all right okay folks we are gonna be
right back on stage shortly with a demo
for alien isolation but first we're
gonna check in with lisa foiles and see
how her t3 is going